previously we discussed how to compare
two sequences with each other this is
why our eyes align and now let's discuss
how to find multiple sequence alignment
so how to compare multiple sequences at
once why do we need this statistically
significant similarities between two
sequences becomes more significant if it
presents in many other sequences so if
you compare a lot of similar species and
you find very conservative domain in
this species it is very significant
while when you compare this species
pairwise this conservative sequence may
be not so obvious for example when you
align three remains which we discussed
previously in this lesson you can find
many pairwise similarities between these
three a domains but when you're trying
to compare all of them at once you will
find the similarity which presents
between all of these three sequences and
which can say you something about what
makes these sequences behave similarly
in a Cell
so let's generalize pairwise alignment
to multiple n previously we use two row
matrix for alignment of two sequences
now when we want to represent alignment
of three sequences let's use three row
matrix and we will need to design our
scoring function to score alignments
with more conservative columns higher
than otherwise and our very wise
alignment was a pass in two-dimensional
mcfadden grid
and alignment between three sequences
actually it's a pass in three
dimensional grid for example let's take
a look on alignment of ATGC a ATC and
ATGC here you can see the number of
symbols up to given position written in
a separate vector and for first sequence
is it's 0 1 1 2 3 4 then for a second
sequence it's 0 1 2 3 3 4 and 0 0 1 2 3
4 for the last sequence and we can take
columns a first column of this vectors
second column of these vectors and so
and so forth as a point in
three-dimensional space and our
alignment pass will move from 0 0 0
point which is source in our
three-dimensional Manhattan grid to 1 1
0 2 1 2 1 and so on and so forth and it
will finish at the opposite corner of
this three dimensional grid as it
started in this opposite corner we will
also call it is a sink similarly to our
2-dimensional Manhattan grid and two
dimensional alignment during each step
we took maximum of three values which
were vertically diagonally and
horizontally opposite on this alignment
cell but in multiple dimension space you
will have more neighbors for each cell
for example for 3-dimensional alignment
cell you will need to take a maximum of
7 values and here is dynamic programming
equations for aligning three sequences
you will need
to find the maximum among all seven
neighbors plus score of moving from this
neighbor to the current node and how
about runtime of such algorithm so for
three sequences of length n runtime is
proportional to the number of edges in
this grid similar as before by the
number of edges now is much larger so
it's seven times n cube because each of
n cube node will have seven neighbors to
choose from so keyway alignment where
you want to find alignment between K
sequences will build a k-dimensional
Manhattan graph with n to the power of K
nodes because it's K dimensional cube or
K dimensional rectangle and most nodes
except of boarder ones you'll have 2 to
the power of K minus 1 incoming edges so
overall runtime is proportional to the 2
to the power of K times n to the power
of K and this is very large so this
algorithm will work for small sequences
small number of sequences for many
sequences of small lengths but it won't
work in a feasible time for many long
sequences for example to find a multiple
alignment of 18 sequences of length 18
each you will need more time than the
age of universe and biologists usually
use fast eristic algorithms they that
doesn't guarantee to find optimal
solutions but they guarantee that this
algorithm will finish at the meaningful
time let's discuss heuristics which will
help us to find multiple alignment in
more feasible way every multiple
alignment in the
use pairwise alignment you can take two
rows by any way you want and you will
get pairwise alignment of these two
sequences which is induced from this
multiple length but can we find multiple
alignment from pairwise alignments in
generally no because given a set of
arbitrary pairwise alignments we cannot
construct multiple alignment that
induces them for example if we have
sequences a a a TTT TTT GGG and GGG AAA
we have these three pairwise alignments
which have a four matches each but we
cannot construct multiple alignment of
these three sequences which will induce
all these three pairwise alignment but
what can we do let's consider profile
representation of multiple alignment we
had profiles before in this course and
profile is usually a probability for
each letter to occur in each column so
for these sequences you can see that
first column contains 0 s 1 T 3 C and
one gap and probabilities of C is 0.6
probability of T and the gap is 0.2 so
how can we align sequence against
sequence you already know this this is
what Palo Alto before in this lecture
but can we align sequence against
profile or can we align profile against
profile yes actually we can so allowing
sequence against sequence requires you
to build this Manhattan graph and write
down one sequence horizontally and one
sequence
particularly but you can replace a
sequence with a profile and you can use
values proportional to the values in a
profile to score each edge in a graph
also you can use profile in the second
sequence and you can align these two
profiles in a very similar way that you
aligned two sequences with each other
but for scoring function you need to
also consider probabilities to have a
certain letter in certain sequence and
certain place so how we can use this
fact to find multiple alignment we can
construct simple greedy algorithm we
will calculate all pairwise alignments
between all sequences for example we
have K sequences in the start we will
calculate all pairwise alignments of
these K sequences which is quadratic
number of which is proportional to the
quadratic number of these sequences and
we will find two closest sequences among
all of them and we will join these two
sequences into a profile after this step
we will have K minus 1 sequences well
actually we'll have K minus 2 sequences
in one profile but we know that we can
align profile in the same way as the
align sequences and we will iterate so
on each iteration we will reduce number
of sequences and profiles to align
between each other by one for example
let's take these four sequences
g-a-a-t-t-c a GTC t GA g 88 ET and 3t g
ADC we will find six pairwise alignments
of these sequences and the best one is
alignment between 2nd and 4th sequences
and it has a score 2 so we will join
these two sequences the one profile and
we will add to our pool of sequences we
want to align and now we have a new set
of three sequences to line sequence one
which is originally sequence 1 sequence
3 and new profile and we can iterate we
can construct pairwise alignments
between each of these three sequences
and find closes join them and so on and
so forth
at the last step we will get to a single
profile of multiple alignment this
greedy algorithm is not optimal it may
find not optimal solution but it will
work fast and it will work on most of
the real-world cases so today we learned
a lot about sequence alignment we
learned how to find pairwise alignment
in quadratic time and linear space we
learn how to use a fine gap analysis
which represent real world better for
biological problems we learn how to find
global and local alignments we learn how
to find multiple alignment between many
sequences at once but can you find all
similarities between human mouth and red
genomes given that these genomes contain
of billions of nucleotides can you
rapidly find alignments between human
genome and millions of short reads which
usually obtained by sequences is genome
and our alignment algorithms with
quadratic time practical when we analyze
entire genomes because as I said
mammalian genomes are very large and
when you try to analyze these genomes
quadratic time usually not works and
these questions we will discuss in
future chapters